mind your decisions I'm presh tal Walker
in triangle ABC construct BD so that a
BD is equal to 60 degrees and DBC is
equal to 20 degrees then construct a e
so that BAE is equal to 70 degrees an e
ad is equal to 10 degrees finally
construct de the question is to solve
for angle AED marked as X you're
supposed to solve this using only
elementary methods that means no
trigonometry
I admit I could not solve this problem
and I had to read the solution online
which I will present in the rest of the
video pause if you'd like to give this
problem a try and when you're ready keep
watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
we'll get started by focusing on
triangle a B II angle B is equal to 80
degrees which means the remaining angle
in this triangle is equal to 30 degrees
well then go back to the original
diagram construct DF so that DF is
parallel to a B we'll proceed in the
following steps
well first show that angle D Fe is equal
to 80 degrees that'll be the easy part
we then need to show that FD is equal to
Fe that's the hard part
from there we'll be able to solve that X
is equal to 20 degrees so let's get
started well first consider just the
following similar triangles the reason
they're similar is because DF was
constructed to be parallel to a B so
angle C is equal to 20 degrees which
means the remaining angles will be equal
to 80 degrees we've completed the first
part of the proof well now go to the
hard part of the proof well first
consider the supplementary angles which
will be equal to 100 degrees each now
again let's construct BD which divides
this angle into 60 degrees and 20
degrees in this triangle the remaining
angle must be equal to 60 degrees from
here let's construct a F which
intersects a point G notice that this
triangle will exactly be congruent to
this triangle
therefore angle a FD will be equal to 60
degrees the remaining angle and triangle
FGD must also be equal to 60 degrees and
then by vertical angles we have a 60
degree angle here then in triangle a B G
the remaining angle must be equal to 60
degrees as well we constructed a couple
of equilateral triangles furthermore
angle FA D must be equal to 20 degrees
because angle a as a whole is equal to
80 degrees we've thus constructed an
isosceles triangle as follows the sides
opposite the 20 degree angles must be
equal to each other so AF must be equal
to FC now return to the diagram and then
let's draw in AE again recalling that we
had a 10 degree angle here from the
original information
the remaining angle must be equal to ten
degrees so that we have a total sum of
20 degrees we're then going to bisect
angle C which will intersect at Point G
these will be two ten degree angles we
now have a couple of congruent triangles
notice the triangle AGC is exactly
congruent to triangle CEA therefore AG
is exactly equal to C e what this means
is the remaining segments f g and f e
will have the same length
from here we go back to the equilateral
triangle of FG d and since it's
equilateral we must have F G equal to FD
consequently FD is equal to F E and we
prove in this part now how do we solve
the problem we go back to the original
diagram and recall that we calculated
that angle D Fe is equal to 80 degrees
so we'll now focus on triangle DF e we
have an isosceles triangle or one angle
the vertex angle is equal to 80 degrees
the two equal angles must be equal to 30
degrees plus X so we have the following
equation 2 x 30 plus X plus ad is equal
to 180 we subtract 80 from both sides we
then divide by 2 and then we simplify
and subtract both sides by 30 and we get
that X is equal to 20 degrees and that's
the answer it was a long journey but it
was a satisfying one
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on YouTube as
always thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
[Music]